[Musica]
[Applauso]
iniziamo con una buona notizia non c'è
nessun pianeta da salvare la terra non
ha nessun bisogno di essere salvata
siamo noi che abbiamo bisogno di essere
salvati per poter continuare a vivere in
questo pianeta che se guardassimo dallo
spazio
scopriremmo essere completamente blu il
7 decimi del nostro pianeta sono
completamente coperti dall oceano e
quindi probabilmente lo chiameremo
pianeta mare e sono proprio questi sette
decimi e proprio l'oceano il blu che ci
dona la possibilità di avere una
temperatura ci regola la temperatura
dove abitiamo e soprattutto ci donerà
due dei tre respiri che faremo adesso
tutti insieme l'oceano ci dona
l'ossigeno tramite la fotosintesi di
alcune alghe si chiamano fitoplancton e
sono delle microalghe che fioriscono
letteralmente in questi oceani
vastissimi insieme alle foreste
amazzoniche ci danno la possibilità di
respirare immaginate che queste micro
alghe dipendono dalle balene per poter
vivere queste micro alghe prendono il
nutrimento dalle balene che con le loro
migrazioni coi loro tuffi miscelano
l'acqua e portano i nutrienti dove
altrimenti non arriverebbero quindi noi
viviamo e respiriamo grazie alle balene
perché se muoiono le balene muoiono gli
oceani e se muoiono gli oceani moriremo
anche noi è proprio per questo che il
capitano paul watson nel 1977 inizia una
grandissima battaglia chiamata una
missione impossibile
inizia con portare una nave fondando sea
shepherd un'organizzazione che pratica
l'azione diretta diversamente da tutte
le altre quindi interviene sul fronte
per fermare documentare investigare e
quando necessario collaborare con i
governi per fermare la distruzione
appunto degli oceani il capitano paul
watson arriva fino in fondo al mondo per
noi marinai l'antartide al post più
inospitale della terra è la fine del
mondo lui arriva lì per fermare un
intero governo il governo giapponese e
dopo 12 anni vince questa grandissima
battaglia dopo 12 anni
grazie al supporto di tutte le persone
che ci hanno aiutato arriva a portare il
tribunale in tribunale il governo del
giappone e lo condannano per baleneria
commerciale mascherata da ricerca
scientifica
davide contro golia paul watson rende
possibile l'impossibile 6.000 balena
nuotano libere negli oceani oggi grazie
a quell azione che ha fatto la
differenza
quell'azione ispira ma nel 2010 fondo
sea shepherd in italia incontro una
persona che diventa mio amico mi insegna
a rispettare il mare si chiama si
chiamava enzo maiorca e la sua famiglia
è tuttora mia carissima amica e
collaboriamo tutti i giorni per la
protezione del mare proprio enzo che ci
aiuta in un'operazione per liberare un
animale che entra a rischio d'estinzione
il tonno rosso nel mare mediterraneo nel
2010 liberiamo 800 tonni rossi da delle
gabbie illegali e nel 2014 con la figlia
patrizia iniziamo operazione siracusa
una seconda campagna di sea shepherd
italia dove in mezzo a un'area marina
quella che doveva essere protetta la
biodiversità che c'è nelle aree marine
deve dare ricchezza a tutto quello che
c'è intorno deve dare ricchezza al mare
alla biodiversità che può diventare il
nostro scudo contro l'estinzione
ed è proprio questa campagna dove
schieriamo 30 persone armate di
telecamere di radio si mettono a
pattugliare di giorno e di notte
incessantemente e dopo sei anni quella
quello sguardo che c'era di
rassegnazione iniziale in quegli uffici
che ho visto a siracusa oggi si è
tramutato in uno sguardo di
determinazione che le cose si possono
cambiare perché dopo 120 operazioni
fermate dopo più di 200 volontari
impegnati a dare il loro tempo le cose
stanno cambiando il pesce non ho più
paura di andare vicino all'uomo
la battaglia si può vincere e noi
iniziamo
nel mentre un'altra operazione
operazione siso prende il nome da un
capodoglio il capodoglio che purtroppo
un capodoglio che muore per colpa di una
rete spadara nel mare nel nostro
mediterraneo
esistono ancora dei sistemi criminali di
pesca lunghi decine di chilometri delle
reti altre 42 metri che uccidono
qualsiasi cosa al loro passaggio sono
bannate da 20 anni dalle nazioni unite
sono chiamate si sono guadagnate il nome
di muri della morte proprio portandoci
l'evidenza morendo davanti ai nostri
occhi che il capodoglio senso ci
costringe ad intervenire ci guarda negli
occhi morendo dicendo ci fate qualcosa
e a quel punto noi interveniamo andiamo
a caccia di bracconieri collaborando con
la guardia costiera collaborando con la
guardia di finanza con le autorità
italiane e l'anno scorso
cominciamo con la confisca di una di
queste reti e proprio operazione siso
quella che è in atto in questo momento
nelle acque del mediterraneo le app del
mare più sovrasfruttato del mondo dove
abbiamo la battaglia la più grande
battaglia che non possiamo permetterci
di perdere la battaglia per salvare mare
mediterraneo che se muore moriranno gli
altri oceani e moriremo anche noi
ed è proprio questa battaglia che stiamo
combattendo con un sogno che si è
realizzato una nave dedicata al
mediterraneo che ci è stata donata
proprio durante la pandemia si chiama
conrad e rimarrà qui insieme alla
passione dei nostri volontari che sono
in questo momento a bordo e che ieri
sera mi hanno chiamato perché la conad è
stata stanotte speronata da un
peschereccio illegale che ci ha
minacciato le loro minacce diventeranno
anche la nostra determinazione perché
vuol dire che stiamo andando nella
giusta rotta per cambiare le cose
ed è proprio nella conrad che tornerò
domani
[Musica]
proprio quella rete che avete visto
legata ad una nave della guardia
costiera era la squadra che abbiamo
confiscato l'anno scorso c'erano 39
animali morti noi sandri a bordo uno
dopo l'altro speravamo di trovarne uno
di vivo ed il quarantesimo era una
verdesca uno squalo blu di tre metri
appena sentito l'acqua è stato liberato
da questa rete ha ricominciato a notare
davanti ai nostri occhi
cosi a simbolo che si può fare si
possono cambiare le cose bisogna agire
per fare la differenza ed è proprio
quello che ti chiederò a voi con la
prima cosa fate volontariato
agite per costruire le vostre passioni
donate il vostro tempo è la vostra
passione per attività e per
organizzazioni come si sa perché rendono
la difesa dell'ambiente una priorità
lo stesso ted l'ambiente dove siamo è
stato fatto grazie al volontariato per
me è un anno speciale io per dieci anni
ho fatto il volontario di sea shepherd e
questo è il mio anno in cui l'undicesimo
in cui donerò la mia intera vita alla
difesa degli oceani quindi mi dedicherò
completamente a questo la seconda
dobbiamo adesso fare un grande
cambiamento non possiamo più acquistare
il pesce in questo momento gli oceani si
stanno svuotando per cinque anni ci
dobbiamo almeno 5 anni fermare tutti
quanti
immaginate due numeri 100.000 o 100
milioni qual è secondo voi il numero di
squali che uccidiamo in un anno e 100
milioni il numero noi uccidiamo ogni
anno 100 milioni di squali questo numero
non è sostenibile immaginate se fossero
nazioni l'italia intera scomparirà bene
un anno poi la francia poi la germania
quanto ci metteremo a estinguere un
intera specie per quelli che pensano già
che non sia possibile
non fatevi allevare dalle abitudini
siate curiosi agite verso un cambiamento
e cominciate con l'eliminare per esempio
la parte illegale
sapete quanto pescato il legale c'è nel
nostro mare da dove io arrivo dove c'è
la cordata in questo momento il su
tirreno
40 per cento di pescato illegale quasi
un pesce su 2 e infine il grande
countdown che abbiamo davanti è quello
di new york dove avete visto che c'è un
orologio che segna che mancano sette
anni alla fine ha la possibilità alla
fine dell'azione c'è la possibilità di
poter fare qualcosa fra sette anni il
cambiamento climatico agira e non
potremo più farci niente
ed è proprio contro questo countdown che
noi dobbiamo agire ognuno di noi ha il
dovere di agire per trovare il suo modo
di creare un mondo di interdipendenza
verremo ricordati dalle generazioni
future come dei pazzi o come degli eroi
e oggi qui con tutti voi
possiamo costruire l'inizio di eroi
nuovi eroi per un nuovo mondo buon
countdown
[Applauso]